[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight veteran members of both parties
in Washington suddenly seem pretty
excited about forcing the president from
office without bothering to call an
election well call that what you will
it's not democracy not that they care
they just want their power back but
before that happens we have some
questions for the permanent class in
Washington about what exactly it is they
believe and what they plan to do if they
retake power that's just ahead but first
in case you are starting to sour on
Donald Trump after all the drama of the
last week Barack Obama reappeared today
to remind us why America elected Trump
in the first place in a remarkable
departure from tradition and decorum
Obama gave a bitterly partisan campaign
speech at the University of Illinois at
champaign-urbana in which he urged
voters to support Democrats in the
midterm elections like virtually all
Obama speeches the subtext was mostly
about the omnipresence of white racism
which Obama needless to say blamed for
the rise of Trump but then he got
creative watch for example as Obama
blames the current administration for
pursuing almost exactly the same Russia
policy that he once did what happened to
the Republican Party its central
organizing principle in foreign policy
was the fight against communism and now
they're cozying up to the former head of
the KGB how did a guy from Hawaii learn
to talk like that where do you get that
accent it's pretty funny but that was
just an aside soon Obama went back to
his favorite and endlessly recurring
theme Republican racism here's one quote
each time we painstakingly pull
ourselves closer to our founding ideals
that all of us are created equal endowed
by our creator with certain inalienable
rights somebody somewhere has pushed
back in other words Republicans just
hate equal rights that's why they
elected Trump they're just like
slaveholders in the antebellum south
watch Obama explain
understand this is not just a matter of
Democrats versus Republicans or liberals
versus conservatives at various times in
our history this kind of politics has
infected both parties Southern Democrats
were the bigger defenders of slavery
slavery say it's simple
racism did it interestingly the one
thing Obama didn't mention was the death
of the American middle class and that's
odd because it was only in 2015 seven
years into Obama's presidency when the
middle class became a minority in this
country for the first time in living
memory that was the pivotal event of the
past several decades it changed this
country profoundly it is the cause of
nearly all of our current political
turmoil but to Obama it simply never
happened and of course seven years of
his policies had literally nothing to do
with it throughout Washington
establishment figures burst into
applause when they heard that they don't
want to talk about the dying middle
class either they're not interested and
they don't want to be implicated so much
easier just to blame racists under the
bed Chris on is a radio show host in New
York and a former staffer to Senator
Chuck Schumer and he joins us tonight so
Chris is it really that simple I mean
that the president said today if you if
you read the speech carefully as I did
what most Democrats have been saying for
the last years it's just racism all this
is racism people couldn't aren't
Republicans rural people these couldn't
deal with all the equality and so
there's a backlash and they elected
Trump is that really the explanation do
you think yeah I don't think that's
really what he said today and I think
that's what he said for anybody
I think it's rich for anybody to say
that norms were not being filed today
which is what you opened with today
because norms have not been followed for
the last 20 months by this president and
I think it's touched every good American
started pushing back and I think
President Obama's speech today was a
rallying cry to the entire country okay
it was it was a campaign speech designed
to get Democrats elected he's a Democrat
I'm not begrudging yeah but I said just
make two points one if you're against
overturning norms that
surely it must bother you that a
recently retired president is giving a
campaign speech we have a norm that they
don't do that he just did and since
you're a defender of norms you're not
bothered no I just don't think that the
the people who love freedom and love our
Constitution in this country should
universally disarm to a president who
has decided to push every norm including
calling on the president including hold
on Tucker including calling on the press
to turn someone over to the government
which you know ok the Republican Party
usually think that Obamacare was tyranny
don't you think that's more tyrannical
right right yeah you're talking okay
whatever it's it's also it's such a
talking point so you look that's fine
then just don't ever lecture me about
norms again if it's bad for Trump to
overturn norms which he's certainly done
I'm not denying that obviously he has
completely Obama's he has and Obama just
did it again today but that's cool and
what Trump is doing is bad because why
stop lecturing me about norms please but
let's get back to the race thing look
cuz I think it's real Obama
I read the speech I watched the speech
again and again he says this is part of
a long cycle in American history says it
out loud where we enfranchise certain
groups in the country and certain
reactionary elements hate that and so
they strike back that's out Trump kook
he just said that he blamed us on racism
and I'm asking you do you think that's
true is that really what the Trump
election was about racism I watched the
speech and then I read it again in
preparing for this show and President
Obama said that there are genuinely
people in this country that fear change
and it's not because of race that's what
he said today okay are there people in
this country are there people in this
country that have a racial element to
their politics of course there are
Tucker we both agree on that yeah Obama
is first on that list I would say but
let me ask you I don't honestly don't
you think if you're assessing what's
going on in America and Obama fancies
himself this intellectual as you know
and you guys pretend he is an
intellectual shouldn't you mention the
death of the middle class in your speech
during his presidency the middle class
for the first time in anyone's lifetime
Minori in this country that caused a ton
of anxiety that in my view resulted in
from selection he doesn't even mention
that no one ever mentions that why I'm
sure the president took over President
Obama took over an economy that was
bleeding jobs and he resuscitated it
including many industries that would
have just gone away had it not been for
the policies of the Obama administration
and you're right the middle class did
take a hit during the Obama
administration as it had done by the in
the Bush administration as well yes I
agree
look I'm not inspiring this because I'm
not a mindless partisan I'm not
defending george w not by the way let's
be clear i don't think it is and i'm not
here to tell republicans who i attack
regularly in the show i just want
someone to stop lying and concede that
all of this is not about racism it's
about the death of our middle class
which does stay in the country for a
hundred years can you admit that III
think that the the pressure on the
middle class is something that has
absolutely contributed to our politics
tucker and it has also caused people who
are who are under stress to take it out
in ways that are not necessarily good
yeah that's why maybe chicks from so
races yeah alright should fix the
problem and I don't think that this
president's capable doing it
yeah maybe a screaming racist will fix
the problem maybe well Chris thank you